people always comment about your
humility and the way you kind of handle
all this attention I wonder how has it
been overwhelming at all to see the
amount of love you were you received
from this franchise and people around
the city know it has because the thing
that keeps me grounded is I just always
think about the times when like it was
just me my stepdad and the basketball on
outdoor court so that's all I need to
keep me grounded can you just talk us
through the last 24 hours and tell us
what that's been like for you just the
whole whirlwind it's been just a lot you
came I'm still taking it in you know I
dreamt about having my name called a lot
of Commissioners he's also a kid and for
him to call my name first
man even more to me and how my family
and friends ever support me I think just
made that moment much better and as the
rest of it it's just sleep be on a plane
and press conference when you hear David
Griffin say that you are not the savior
of the pelicans franchise do you think
that that takes some of the weight off
of your shoulders coming into the league
as a rookie just knowing that the weight
of an entire franchise is not on just
you like I said before I look at things
from a realistic point of view I think
people are kind of doing a bit much I am
18
I haven't even played one game yet so
I'm I look at it just like that like I'm
just trying to come contribute to the
team whatever the vets need me to do I'm
I'm ready to do it last night you
addressed the people in New Orleans you
said let's dance what was the origin of
that was that something just popped in
your head or was there some background
to that funny story about that so me and
a group of friends we want to see
Avengers in game and if you know me
Thanos is my favorite character so
you know Captain America's shield is
broken and I'm like we're about to land
like for once the movies got to be
realistic and the bad guy wins sometimes
the strongest so my friend Axl
he's like Hodor ha all of a sudden all
these superheroes who disappeared five
years ago just start appearing and I'm
like huh might lose and he looks at me
he goes let's dance
[Laughter]